hello and welcome to the gamespot after
dark podcast episode 155 i am your host
tomorrow saying joined by the podfather
himself jake decker hello i'm back i'm
i'm a local now i'm a local local well
yeah i don't know if i'm technically a
local no you're local enough you're
local to us yeah local california yeah
yeah i got that going for me
we're we're glad that you're back um
also here is lucy james hi
i'm i'm i'm here i'm on i'm i've i
haven't my back my laptop ran out of
battery and apparently so did i
exactly yeah what did you say something
like almost fell off a cliff there
but i understand it and i can relate and
we're also joined by
newcomer yeah so the gamespot team
the one
the only oh my god stu
campbell hey everybody do you know how
difficult it is but i mean
[Music]
yeah i'm a cop you idiot
you have no idea how many times honestly
i get stopped yeah okay
i will be saying i'm a cop you idiot to
you a lot okay good because i know that
you've probably had it um every day of
your life yeah and honestly i don't care
yeah because and if we're going to do
anything here it's running it's a run a
joke
into the ground but yes stuart uh do you
want to tell people about yourself a bit
we have a
uh
a segment that we haven't used in a
really long time i can't even remember
the name
the the chris from dayton ohio yeah what
are you talking about
it's jackson jackson
yeah jackson actually listens and is in
the discord and he's in the discord so
shout out to jackson chris
be more like jackson not don't be a
chris jackson yeah but the uh the
segment is obviously introducing
yourself telling us what you do at
gamespot and then telling us some of
your pertinent background
and stuff you like generally so people
can you know develop parasocial
relationships with you beautiful i love
you it's great yeah
um i am stuart kimball as they've said
before uh i am from san francisco bay
area marin county specifically you are a
local i am a very cool um
and i just
three days ago started at gamespot
uh and i am an associate video producer
that is my technical title um and things
i like um i am a huge hai miyazaki fan
uh any chance i can get to watch those
movies i will
um the from software guy right yeah
exactly oh my god so making sure don't
give him don't let him anything from
soft yeah yeah yeah um what else a huge
yakuza fan even though i'm not
very into this
series yet i've only played zero and
started kiwami but huge fan that's funny
all gonna be on ps plus are you fine
you only really need to play
the first yuck is that one yakuza game
will turn you into a huge fan of that
series and zero will be there
yeah
um
what else about me canadian spoon asks
for one awkward secret
which you don't have to reveal but that
is a fun prompt yeah um if canadian
spoon is awesome for it you have to i
don't people don't know this but you
can't develop parasocial relationships
without giving a little bit first
canadian spirit is very important in our
twitter
status so we have to give him we can
always come back to it later though you
can't think of anything off the top of
your head well the first thing that
comes to mind is actually the very
embarrassing and um kind of
graphic in a bathroom-related way let's
go
um i had to
i had to uh i had to go to the bathroom
in the middle of central park once oh no
i was at a concert for i was seeing
japanese breakfast oh that's good um
amazing concert i don't know what i ate
japanese breakfast
exactly and um
i
i got
it was an emergency you know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
you've got minutes yes literal minutes
so there was a giant tournament
no
peeking out you know
uh yeah exactly groundhogging um
and and so i was in the middle of
central park and there was this giant
rock
i don't even know where it is in central
park i don't need to say that because i
don't want if you are based in new york
oh god a voice
a voice some stew's poo is still there
yes exactly uh so yeah i went behind
this rock in central park i was like
with people too so i'd be like oh i'm so
sorry i gotta go to the bathroom like
see you later
she seems scary
and you can
it rip that's it okay that's it cause i
was like it was it was night time but i
was still like i don't need anybody to
see this like i mean i think you'd get
arrested right that's what i was worried
about i was it was it got to the point
where i was running
um and so that's where i was like oh
[ __ ] how did you
clean
uh
leaf
[Laughter]
no no we're digging in now this is the
good stuff i think we already know the
answer no you know
no
okay can you explain i don't know the
sock is the easier one to get rid of
yeah but he's been at a concert in
central park oh you don't want to be a
sweaty dirty sock
i mean no you can't no i understand like
you can poop directly into a sock yeah
time is talking about a very specific oh
situation
oh yeah i've not done it oh okay i've
not done it now but i've i've known
people where actually have i pooped
[ __ ] up i have poop socks one time
when oh i was very sick and it was
it was one of those i'm about to let rip
and i do not have the time to
make it to i was in my apartment
tactical socks it wasn't it wasn't here
it wasn't this is all your fault
i do not i have the facility but i'm
like also sick and weak i don't think
you have the facilities for that baby
definitely didn't have this for that big
man um but like i was like i don't have
the energy and i was like feverish
i just gotta go in this sock and tie it
up and this it's a clean you know why
it's good because once you've done it in
the sock right you can use the top of
the sock to wipe
i didn't even think about that yep
that's really exposed the entire thing
tactical socks you rather be one sock
down than entire underpants down yeah
yeah i'm saying but then you're you're
you're too soft well because you can't
you can get rid of the other side i
guess you can get rid of that you can
just keep the other stuff it's not
really a problem but what do you do with
the other i know you could use the other
socks because in the bin
yeah yeah yeah yeah easy yeah
you just
if you need to get rid of the other one
use it as a pea socks pizza so
it's fine
anyways what are your favorite video
games of all time
um now that we know that you absolutely
[ __ ] in public
yeah see that's what i was trying to
avoid yeah just there's no way you can
end this conversation that's what i was
trying to avoid i was behind someone on
the um escalator in the underground and
um he just shot himself in front of me
yeah
i did say it was going to come and you
didn't move back
but no i remember he tried to like
wiggle it down the leg and i was like
i'm just going to walk around oh
absolutely wiggle it down the leg
get it down the trousers
anyway
yeah what are you what games you like
video game of all time
and what genres are you into
um
oh god favorite video game of all time
uh
i would say metal gear solid two
yeah that's that's definitely a favorite
this is good this is good i do don't
know yourself to him this is great
am i right now i mean i saw the kids
saying the right things oh okay yeah
what can i say that will make them angry
you want to make me angry
um
uh i played all of those during like the
beginning of the lockdown and i think
that was definitely like just such a
standout experience um oh so you're
fresh to the series yes exactly oh
that's amazing yeah and it became your
favorite game of all time it's just so
oh it's so well done yeah two is pretty
great lucy just finished it recently
yeah i finished yeah i finished two
recently um have you started three no
well because i'm figuring out what i'm
doing
re-international travel
and
re-international travel
uh
so i didn't want to start playing it and
then take you know a two-week break to
go back to the uk yes which would have
been yeah uh but then i got
i took a two-week break to be
chronically ill
we laugh because i'm just a tired [ __ ]
but um no so i'll probably start it in
september because also as well i'm
working with
i guess i'm allowed to say it
because
i guess i'm the client in this case i'm
working with amanda flag from ign to
redo all of my stream assets and stuff
so i wanted to kind of relaunch my stuff
with new assets and things so um
didn't you just do three
i just finished three yeah yeah so i
just finished three but i've played
three many many times um yeah also yeah
i think this is a fantastic game yeah um
so that's your favorite game with him
too
impressive yeah just off the top of my
head i'll probably yeah
um
what is
a video game moment that made you cry if
any
really getting vulnerable well i've
already talked about tubing at central
park
um
no i i think the one that we're gonna
get more vulnerable okay oh we're gonna
actually from the heart um
the
uh first 15 minutes of the last of us
gets me every time
every single time yeah uh it really hits
me when it's like new game continue
options
the breeze blowing in the window it's
just oh my god you went to that event in
um london where they they recreated just
that window yep uh it was like in a
rundown old theater i think it was and
they did like this last of us event and
um
uh
you know uh neil druckmann was there and
everyone and uh troy baker i think was
that australian um
they sort of made it look
post-apocalyptic and run down and then
there was a point where they just
had the window blowing in the breeze and
i was like damn okay did they have their
own outside blowing up no it was just
someone going
okay with a big book yeah
they do the thunder thing where it rolls
a little bit so lost the bus is yes
gives you okay cool yeah that's yeah oh
what's your most controversial gaming
opinion that's from jacob mccoy
oh my god jesus off the
controversial gaming opinion um this
better be good otherwise you have to
tell another embarrassing story i know
is that the the stakes yeah yeah um
i
i am
i'm not a big souls fan
no that's how you make there you guys i
know
i agree i i i respect them
like them i don't think i've ever beaten
one i've tried
i'm just bad i guess yeah it sounds like
it um
a final question or
what a video game character do you want
to shag
oh tim this is my direct report
just say who's attractive who do you
want to shag
which one which video game character do
you want like the most manager lucy that
i will be oh
i didn't i didn't step in about you
shoot yourself in the box
editor of gamespot.com you will answer
my questions that's true and i've made
you angry um
i i don't know
um
come on um let's go
um
what's uh
uh claire right from resonance redfield
there you
that's a go one
uh thank you for that now you know
everyone knows uh all the information
they need to form a parasocial
relationship thank you if you want to
now yeah that's yeah yeah he is uh he
likes mega solid two he wants to check
hr is on east coast time so i don't give
him the opportunity to poo he will [ __ ]
just out in public
and throw his underwear into the sea
yes as it has it happened let's kick
over to the uh first section of this
podcast in which we discuss what we've
been playing we're going to start with
jake
all right i mean i figured i'd just talk
about xenoblade chronicles 3. you
technically did review it i did review
it i haven't really played anything the
past week because i've been moving but i
obviously finished that game up and
reviewed it
uh i like it a lot i think it has some
of the best combat in a jrpg ever at
least in my opinion
uh it depends if you're into that sort
of mmo
uh sort of auto attack sort of battling
system if you are
i think you'll definitely dig it if not
might be a harder sell uh that said
though
uh i i haven't played it in a week but i
am still thinking about different
strategies different different
characters classes different abilities i
might swap in is that because it's
really compelling or is it because you
just didn't have internet for a very
long time and just didn't have anything
else to do i mean i i read a lot
actually
so yeah i didn't have anything else to
do really
um but no it's always good also it's
good yeah the the combat is really good
i'm a little more lukewarm on the story
i think the story does some really cool
stuff obviously i won't get into
spoilers
uh however the moment dialogue is really
cringy in my opinion i know i know
there's people out there who are gonna
be like well you do
this this is actually good dialogue if
you play these kind of games it's like
look i play jrpgs
i know i yeah i i play jrpgs yeah
people can know that
um
but it just doesn't feel as sharp it
feels uh a lot of it feels bogged down
by
proper nam made up proper nouns of
things that
in that and there's no codex so i don't
really know what people are referencing
especially early on they're just saying
words which you know it it depends how
invested you're going to be into that
story if you are really into xenoblade
which to be fair i am but if you're
going to sit there and you're going to
learn
all the nitty gritty of that world you
probably won't have much trouble but i
think the fact that you have to sit
there and learn all this stuff shows
that the onboarding in the game isn't
the best
but once it gets going i think the
story's pretty good does some neat
things um
how much has it evolved over previous
games that combat system because i've
only like i played all of one i dipped
into two and i was like there's no rhyme
in this
so
it is more closely related to xenoblade
chronicles 1 i would say
two
it doesn't bring back that sort of
elemental burst system that they had
into which which to be fair i did really
like this one builds more on one's
combat uh but instead of having three
members on the battlefield you have six
well technically seven because there's a
hero class that you can't control but
they'll assist in different ways you'll
have six so you'll have two tanks two
healers two dps
um that you will be able to swap between
uh and plus all of those different
characters you can swap classes with and
there's like
there's like 25 23 classes or something
like that
so there is a lot to work with uh and it
it is a lot of menu management if you
don't like menu management
you might not get the most out of the
combat that said if you're still
interested and you don't want to deal
with menus you can drop the difficulty
and you can auto load characters so you
don't you can just choose their class
press a button it'll equip them with uh
gems and accessories and whatever it is
so you can't make it easy on yourself i
personally don't think i would have
liked the game nearly as much though if
uh
if if i just did that but i am also that
person who does love digging into menus
and it you know turns into like a little
excel spreadsheet sort of game right um
it's really good though i i highly
recommend it even if you've never played
xenoblade i think
i think there's a lot to enjoy i think
if you've never played a xenoblade you
might have trouble getting into it
initially but i think once it gets going
uh it does some does some really cool
things
nice cool um
what i was gonna say is uh crap i had a
question in my mind but it's completely
gone out man how long did you play it
for like what is what is the kind of
like
the meat versus fat ratio in the game so
i think so i did a lot of side stuff and
it took me about 100 hours that said i
didn't do all the side stuff there's
still a lot of side stuff i haven't done
yet
i would say you could probably finish it
in
70 to 80 hours if you want to rush it i
finished it in 100 but then i went back
for an extra like 25 hours i i would
probably still be playing um
if i wasn't in the middle of a move but
yeah i did about 125 hours went got all
the classes leveled up most of the
classes leveled up most the characters
uh there's also a lot of really cool
post-game areas uh so there are
really tough bosses that you can't find
i mean i guess you can find you just get
your ass kicked early on that you
actually have to build up and train for
plus there's new game plus like in the
other games so
if you want to go back and level up more
try out different things um it's fun i'm
actually really tempted to do new game
plus because now that i've unlocked all
the classes and i've unlocked
all the different skills and and and
stuff like that i want to go back and
see what that game is like when i can be
firing off at all cylinders right from
the beginning right right um what's a
like quality is there a quality
disparity between main stuff and side
stuff like if i um if you are the kind
of person to do side stuff is it going
to be rewarding or is it just going to
be like
my name is mildred please help me find
my pan so there's a lot of that there's
a lot of uh
kind of low priority side stuff that you
can do um there is also some really
important side stuff a lot of the heroes
you get which give you classes are only
achieved through doing this side stuff
and those side quests are marked yellow
and they're fully voiced they introduce
new characters new classes so they're
they're pretty good
i would recommend doing those uh even if
you don't want to do side stuff i would
still do all the hero stuff because like
i said combat's the best best part of
this game in my opinion and
to get the most out of combat you really
need to get all of those classes
is there stuff like recruiting
characters that you might otherwise not
see in side quests okay cool and then
each of those characters have an extra
quest that kind of
wraps up their story that levels up
that increases their max level more so
each of these main characters have like
or each of these different class
characters like i said 23 to 25 uh have
two bespoke quests that are fully voiced
have their own villains and whatnot so
some of the bosses get a little
repetitive but uh
i think i think ign's review they kind
of mark that as a downside of the game
that the boss is repetitive but i found
the combat to be so
enjoyable and so malleable that i didn't
really mind it because i was able to
even though the boss was similar i was
able to play it in a very different way
every time
how does it perform is the switch how is
the switch handling that what switch did
you play on i played on an oled i mostly
played docked i played probably like 10
handheld i would say
uh it for the most part it's fine i mean
i didn't have any frame rate dips until
one specific part
uh the resolution is
what you'd expect from a switch i guess
it's not great draw distances are pretty
noticeable
uh some technical issues here and there
i don't think it should prevent anyone
from playing this if you're into it but
it definitely in the back of my mind
i was just thinking man where's that
switch pro
cause it's a huge game it's clear that
they're pushing the power of the
nintendo switch
in different ways and it just feels old
now
um even with the oled which you know i
got less than a year ago
um but it's colorful it's really
colorful the the areas i think are
really well designed um interesting a
lot of fun to explore
but it's just that in the back of my
mind it's like oh this could look a
little better a little better yeah
yeah i think i want to check it out but
i think i'm prioritizing
live alive first
oh i did see um a friend of the show
andrew goldberg sent me a clip of live
alive
of some spicy uh
dialogue and i was like i had no idea
this game was like this yeah
i just started playing it was on my desk
actually before we came in here um and
it's yeah it seems cool i barely played
any enough to to kind of give a good um
take on it but our review of it's very
positive and it's it's had like a long
and storied history of being a game that
people generally love and say holds up
and
basically everyone i've heard talking
about it that hasn't played it before
and is playing it for the first time
says it's like very
unique it's still not a lot of other
rpgs jrpgs are trying to do anything
like it which is
kind of fun but yeah i'm excited to
delve into that and then i think i might
go to xenoblade after if i still have it
in me to play another jrpg yeah
yeah anything else that you've been
playing or watching or reading or
anything like that i mean not really
like i said mostly moving i guess i've
been reading a book called sapiens which
is fascinating but i don't think
yeah it's a
book yeah right so it's about
it's about uh bts and stuff
i love bts
um stew
what have you been playing what have you
been watching um playing i've been
switching between a couple different
things i've been doing um cyberpunk
which i've actually been loving uh that
was the first time
first time i i downloaded it um when it
or
bought it when it came out and have just
waited until the you know patches came
out how is it now it i was describing it
the other day as the best bethesda game
i've ever played like if you hold it to
that standard
it
slaps like it's so good in that way um
not technical issues not really anymore
it's good which is good it's only
crashed on me once i think playing it on
ps5 um
yeah the story lines inside missions are
it's it's the opposite of the mildred
pan yeah like every single one those cd
projekt red side missions are so deep
and so
fun to play um yakuza uh kiwami i've
been going back and forth between that
cyberpunk
uh i started one piece before this job
um because oh my god wait so how how
long
were you out of a job before you got
this job uh like
two months oh yeah i think because one
month was like yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
there's like a period where you you most
people who have nothing else going on
will be like
i've hit the bomb in the barrows one
piece time when did you start watching
1p oh i i started watching one piece
when i was
in
college i think or university one of
those two and i literally i got to the
point where i had given up so hard that
i reoriented my entire life around
watching one piece oh my god to the
point where i got a mattress and i put
it down in front of my pc so i could lay
down
and sleep there as well so i'd wake up
in the morning
i'd sit down on my pc and start watching
one piece and i'd eat nothing but cheese
toasties
three four times a week a day and then
when i was done
two three a.m i'd go
out my chair into the mattress and sleep
and wake up and then watch one piece
cheese toasties sleep how are you i did
that for like
maybe three months three or four oh my
god um yeah how much one piece did you
get i watched me
like two percent of it right yeah
one and a half ox or something like that
i got a fair weight into it but like
didn't didn't get like
caught up all the way i was watching it
like in the early days as well so like
okay um
but yeah that's when people when people
started watching one piece you have to
be like are you all right yeah you
didn't do it
okay
no i just had nothing else to do but
it's good for that though right it's so
good what do you think of it i i love it
so far i'm truly only maybe like
10 episodes in or something i was not
far yet and i had the expectation of
like oh this is going to take me my
entire lifetime or after my lifetime
it's over a thousand episodes right now
right yes something like that yeah yeah
no it's it's really good just getting
introduced to the whole crew and yeah i
mean that's the crew keeps growing yep
the crew keeps growing so first arc is
is it
the sharks
is it sharks they are sharks right well
who's the who what's the first arc about
uh the main villain in it
i don't know if i've even gotten to the
main room okay
it was the clown lady like the beast oh
like that's an episode that i'm going to
yeah yeah yeah and the what is one piece
about it's about pirates basically
they're trying to find uh gold roger's
hidden yes um
treasure so on his deathbed before they
execute him he told the world that there
was he had a hidden
stash of treasure right and he called it
the one piece on the grand line and it
basically reignited the age of pirates
and all these pirates from around the
world suddenly go embark on but there's
like political factions and there's
something called the devil marines
and
it's the devil's fruit way if you
consume it it changes your body to give
you abilities but it also means that
you get those abilities but then if you
hit water you you basically die you're
done so you're a pirate but you're also
the wicked witch of the west yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're just useless in
in like
yeah also terrible pirate can't get wet
right yeah exactly that's the that's the
trailer the 90-10 yeah yeah but yeah the
first arc is though the kobe stuff where
he's like he's it's like exactly um the
kid the annoying kid with the purple
hair oh yes yeah i was like yeah yeah
yeah and because he was on the uh on the
ship
yeah yeah yeah
i think like the first arc is almost
like setting up
the original crew where he goes to find
zorro i've seen them find sanji nami and
nami yeah and the nami stuff is where it
really gets
big big big along park is the first main
arc okay that's really really cool i'm
excited for it honestly yeah it's it's a
lot of fun it has it definitely like
it's one of those ones where
it has its ups and downs and when it's
down it's really down like the the art
takes a hit everything looks like a
child drew it and it's [ __ ] up and
like like in evangelion or like
not in an artistic way not in an
artistic way it just looks like they're
like yeah you're really saving money on
frames yeah um that kind of stuff but
it's still it's still um
people in chat are saying he's olong is
not a shark he's a fish man
he's a shark okay he's a shark unless
he's not i think a shark is a fish right
yeah but like he literally has sharp
teeth and bites
um and like it's like okay he's a fish
man but clearly anyone any normal human
looks at that character and goes that's
a shark
um
but yeah uh alvida is the clown lady
yeah the best character you are yet to
meet is buggy who's uh also
clown oriented okay which is the guy who
when we were in gamescom or you were
determined to get yeah buggy nice
you see the guy with the cannon
the buggy ball yeah yeah yeah yeah i've
seen that
he's so good he's so good is that mark
hamill who voices him it sounded like
the joke i'm watching i watch the
japanese one so i got it um i've been
doing the american okay
the four kids one i hope not no it's
what's ever on okay okay the four kids
ones like back in the day they replace
like sanji is a cook and he smokes
but they like replaced his cigarette
with a lollipop
like they like really censored that show
really like
dragged out the personality from it
um
but yeah um the amount of show for kids
representation online right now is
really good though because netflix has i
think it's netflix has sonic x which i
watched every saturday it's horrible but
it was like that whole lineup oh so good
i love it so much yeah
did you ever watch the kirby show was it
kirby right back at you yeah right back
at you i love that show oh
i haven't seen it i'm surprised
yeah i'm surprised they bring that stuff
back i know that kirby show was really
good even the sonic show was like i mean
the sonic cartoons are currently like
super popular right that's sonic xp
massive massive in the cards
[Music]
roger smith comics and the sonic the
sonic games have absolutely [ __ ] the bed
but in the meantime the comics and the
anime shows and animated shows have been
like just getting better and better and
better and better people most modern
sonic fans that are young or like
teenage probably came through the comic
or the comics or the uh the animated
shows um
but yeah it's awesome what other anime
do you have watched or or
uh bebop is one of my favorite just
pieces of media of all time i got spike
and iron on my desk um
anime-wise i mean if you're doing movies
all of the miyazaki takahata stuff um
uh akira um
it's pretty basic i haven't done a lot
of shows
i like kind of want to go back and do
like maybe bleach i've never seen death
notes
bleach
a lot of edgy internet people are going
to get mad at me but bleach hits the bed
pretty fast
um
yeah it's not great okay um
i just remember but it is iconic from
wreck in the day like if you it had it
had the villain problem where everything
would eventually be the same villain
right it's like oh god it's this guy
again
um he's a different version of this guy
yeah it's just it's just that annoying
thing but it does have some really cool
moments in it that are super super
awesome and characters we tried jojo's
bizarre adventure so my brother got me
into that well i forget uh the one where
they're in italy which
oh uh that's one point
uh phenomenal or no no it was was it was
nice try cesarino
it wasn't that one it was okay egypt
maybe oh so that's
that's
what we've just started watching
stardust crusaders i think yes yes so
that's the one we just
which is technically part two it's part
two
part two yeah second half of part two i
believe if you're going by the netflix
listing oh yeah um no i went in cold my
brother was watching it already and i
just watched something with him okay i
was gonna say yeah so you don't know
oh yeah you don't have spot is a very
jojo aligned
publication okay yeah everyone you know
what a lot of people here are integers
well you i already told you about the
speed wagon zone yes yes
yeah got that reference um
but yeah so you're watching one piece
yeah i'm kind of taking
as weird as it is to take that series
slow i am just because i'm like it's so
much content might as well actually
delve into it especially in those early
seasons where it's probably better maybe
than the later seasons it gets better
does it get better yeah it gets better
it gets much much better and then it
kind of dips here on there as it needs
to to give people time and like
give the animation house a little bit of
a break and create some distance between
the manga and the anime and that kind of
stuff because the manga is done right no
no no no oh it's not okay okay yeah yeah
yeah the manga is like one of the
longest published fictional things ever
at this point
um
but yeah it's i believe it's still going
i mean i am still getting like hey
chapter 1 trillion is out now on my apps
so oh my god i'm guessing that is
the apps but yeah so any other games
uh
uh kirby uh still going through eldon
ring which i actually do really like i
just they take me a long time um
yeah
and then kirby is a palette cleanser for
elden ring
games wise oh stray beat that the other
night nice fantastic
or as we affectionately called the kitty
cat game yeah
in our house i have a fun video about it
on sunday oh nice youtube you're excited
uh i'm watching something
[Music]
secretive that i can talk about
next next week yeah
um i believe
but i am playing straight
but i'm also playing bear and breakfast
which is like
the the main kind of game i've been
playing this week i've only put a few
hours in but it's right what is it
people like it's like animal crossing
but then i see pictures and it looks
like a
a simulation sort of game it's closer to
stardu than animal crossing i would say
but it's also like
you run a bed and breakfast so there's a
little bit of management sim to it okay
resource management as well like going
out and finding stuff in the world and
then crafting
you are a character that movie you are a
bad yes you run you are the bear you are
the best
i'm more interested now the screenshots
i saw
just a sim like a management system
you could you are the bear you go around
you pick up stuff and uh you basically
like you want to get the humans back
because they've kind of they're very
useful to you and the other woodland
creatures because they drop trash
and then you as the bear and all your
friends go through the trash and like
get treasures from it i don't know if it
works that way in real life and we're
doing that now yeah yeah
but you know but what he does is um him
and his his
i think we figured out they were
siblings
they're all like oh i think they're like
a weird family of animals um
a pigeon yeah oh not all bears no not
all just a bear yeah and then you go and
you um do up like a little old
dilapidated shed
and then you start charging humans to
come stay in it and then you decorate it
so there's like an element of the sims
an animal crossing in it this is really
fun it's really well written i'm really
enjoying it i wish i had a steam deck
because i would love to play that lying
down on the couch
valve
if you're listening um no so i've been
playing a bunch of that i'm really
enjoying it but i think this weekend i'm
going to delve into there's a new sims
expansion
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on with the
sims at the minute
they accidentally uh put they actually
turned on incest
in the game
uh accidentally yeah
so like it's it's one of those really
cool things hang on i have to be really
careful
really cool
james 2022
clip that someone close sims the sims
team is uh has been really
really great progressive adding a lot of
things into the game and one of the big
things they did recently was add actual
sexualities to sims like sims sims back
in the day used to be just completely
pansexual pretty much and then in sims 4
at least
um
it wasn't you could never set your sims
sexuality you would just
like through gameplay you would kind of
do it so this one in the in creative sim
you can now say if your sim is attracted
to just men just women
or both
but unfortunately in implementing this
it means that um
some family members are now
listen people are attractive regardless
of blood relations no wait a minute hold
on
hold on and so like they are working on
it but it's it's a part of the um so
what the sims team does they did this
with cottage living last year is
whenever they drop like a big new
expansion typically the summer expansion
they add one thing that sort of creeped
someone out
they changed expansion everyone was
really attracted to chairs they were
like
they make um
really like noticeable improvements to
base game and so what they've done this
time around for example is they've added
um
new decorating stuff in there like
curved walls is huge
sims community is freaking out about
curved walls
um
and then there's other stuff in there
like the sexuality stuff like they put
pronouns in in a smaller update a few
months ago a few weeks ago but now this
was the big one and um yeah they have a
high school
expansion pack
i'm intrigued by because i'm not really
sure how it's going to differentiate
gameplay much from the university pack
that already exists well everybody's
going to recreate twilight that's all it
is
which
already happened
they released a werewolves pack a few
weeks ago and uh jess howard from our
team made twilight and because there's
already a vampire pack as well they made
and don't they like kill you they killed
each other yeah
yeah it ends up like romeo juliet
oh wow so
i'm i'm intrigued to see but there has
also been uh georgia was saying that
there was a an issue where
they've accidentally if you install this
patch all your sims get aged up which
means that loads of people have had like
all of their elder sims have just died
and um georgia was texting our group
thread me her and callie have a group
throat about sims and georgia was like
yeah i'm just i booted up my game and
i'm just in seniorville because all my
sims
have been aged up so i don't know if i
do want to play just yet yeah maybe wait
until they sort that out right
i kind of want to play sims dude
is great at a minute i've been thinking
really deep and and long about
installing sims i haven't played simpson
sims 2. yeah yeah i only played it a
little bit and i was like
i guess i can see why people like this
but i don't think i get it but now i'm
like
i want to [ __ ] with some people
teamstream maybe maybe that's that's
what i should start streaming
we can make some real [ __ ] up families
uh and maybe maybe keep the incest thing
there just to see what happens you can i
mean there was already there was already
mods before i'm sure there's that's dude
that's something everything yeah um you
know
i'm speaking of chairs
you ever sat on those chairs that under
seating area there's a hole
what you like a toilet no no yeah like
for like you have like those wooden
chairs it's got like a slight hole in it
i i used to see those all the time in
like um
is that a british thing maybe a british
thing i always thought it was oh it's
not weird as [ __ ] and i was like what
are you talking about you're sitting on
broken chairs so you know how they had
like in the back of chairs at school as
well they'd have like a like a like a
thing okay
yeah
okay oh okay yeah but they sometimes
they would have them on the bottom part
as well yeah and try to be like what is
that for is it like a fart hole or what
or like in um casino royale
yeah exactly
a little different that was a custom
chair yeah what holes for someone if
chat if you us know what that's all
about anyway carry on sims uh no
canadian spoons asking uh if you can if
you can uh play the sims without having
to make the houses and yes you can
because the gallery is great um and
people just post their creations on
there
is there a good onboarding
oh yeah for sims
for people who are like what are you
talking about
the newbie family
the newbie family was in sims 1. i think
that's the tutorial family in all the
sims games
i'm pretty sure i might start streaming
the sims yeah it could be entertaining
yeah
yeah uh
is it time for sims five four five what
are what's up we're on four of the
minutes
you might because it's been what like a
decade hasn't been 2014
2014 was sims 4. so my
my main issue with the sims as it stands
right now is the and the sims has always
done this ever since one is that it
released like expansion packs
the sims 4 has such a ridiculous number
of expansion packs but they're not just
my expansion packs there are stuff packs
um kit packs
uh some of them is like they have things
like and i hate it because i actually
genuinely do love this expansion uh this
pack uh laundry day stuff
they have a spa day okay you know so
they have like really
particular things this is one of the few
franchises that get gets away with just
micro transactioning literally
everything but
20 and everyone's like sweet because i
got i got um
cottage living is the best expansion
pack that they've done which is
basically cottage core english
countryside
um and at the same time it was like five
bucks so i bought laundry day and i was
like i can live out in the country and
do my laundry and it has like a um a
laundry line i was like i can't hang out
because they make them dry all stuff
that lucy will absolutely not do in real
life yeah no do you know i i had to put
myself on like some kind of schedule to
do my laundry because i was like
because i i have so many meetings on a
monday i was like okay every monday i'll
do my sheets this day and then every
friday i'll do my clothes and it's just
like mine's that's how i get over the
sunday scaries
laundry and i was sitting on a laundry
during the like evening early evening
and then before bed like a couple of
hours
i just
stick something on and just fold my
laundry it's like really really nice
it's like therapeutic and then you're
like all right you finished
the sunday by doing something productive
yeah and then you're also like cleaning
the area as well oh well you know i
i was on tick tock now i'm gonna play
sims though yeah like a goblin
and now you'll not do your real life
yeah yeah
yeah
same see your sims don't have so much
now i write i saw on tick tock someone
said you shouldn't refer to cleaning as
cleaning because that makes it a chore
in your head you should refer to it as
doing a reset
so i'm resetting my bedroom
i think i'm just going to stick with
cleaning because i like the idea of like
resetting your space
no on sunday i could get behind
like reset sunday reset yeah so i'm
going to i refresh i hate folding my
laundry i don't mind doing laundry
i hate folding laundry but i found a
strategy on tick tock on how to fold
yup just it's the other pink
was kind of useless because it happened
too fast so i went to youtube mm-hmm
best way to fold shirts the top five
ways to fold so if you want to level
that up which is what something i used
to do the the uh thing as well i still
do but my younger brother is one of
those people who see something and he's
like
i'm gonna make that better and
he found a
thing that you can construct out of
cardboard which is like this it's like a
series of flaps
my old roommate had just laid down those
yeah yeah yeah
he just closed clothes clothes clothes
he made it and he was like try this and
i did it and i was like
i don't know this is this is really
ripping the joy out of it he made it out
he didn't pioneer it but he saw someone
else
and he made one out of cardboard oh my
gosh just like a you got like an amazon
delivery box a few of them and yeah
and he was like there we go we did it i
think like that because i [ __ ] hate
folding laundry i hate it so much it is
my least favorite chore even if you put
on something in the background like
distract yourself even if i put on
something in the background
i've just typed in laundry folding
device amazon.com
um did you think you'd get this on a
gaming podcast did you think this is
what would happen how to fold your
laundry uh it is as cheap as 15 dollars
you can get one less ugly than that um
you can get different ones and yeah
different colors i might look into that
let's let's here you go you're gonna
jake is gonna see it happen in action
wait wait they cut to a video of a city
shipping
in a world did you see that jake did you
see that even this stupid childhood
idiotic child
oh that's pretty good
they're doing they're they're speed
running right now together mother and
child combo both of them i would love to
see that games done quickly yeah
laundry
crossing the arms that most people
forget that's what messed me up when i
was doing it on youtube
i've been watching the boys season three
which i um i've been really enjoying i
kind of actually didn't watch did you
watch season two oh yeah but i didn't
watch the final episode of season two
until last week because um
sometimes i just like to take a pause in
the middle of doing things hence why i
haven't finished the sopranos yet um
but i started watching that it's really
good and then other than that i've been
very social this week you and callie are
back
i have hang out hung out with you guys
i've been in the office you started i'm
hanging out late yeah we're hanging out
i went to oh well i went to the
bridgeton experience
my friends went to that they loved it
yeah i liked it a lot but 16 bucks
i've been to secret cinema in london
which is like
they i mean the star wars one they
converted a whole factory into um
tatooine and then um the death star so
you know the blade runner one is still
like oh where it was raining indoors
yeah they they basically created the the
opening market scene where you find
edward james almost and and um uh
like
eating they recreated that yeah and it's
like raining there were people about
there was oh they had
chris was doing
acrobatics
and [ __ ] yeah i'm like it was could you
get the noodles too yep yep you could
you could eat noodles um one of us got
arrested who got rested arrested
when was this what year 2017
you're kidding me i was in london
we had to bust you out prison yeah
that's amazing
yeah i love that so i enjoyed the
brigitte and one it was fun um
my friends and i got
pretty drunk nice but we looked great
and had a lovely time that's what
matters and oh it was it was quite funny
because they they have actors so like
there was a queen you could present
yourself to the queen
but and they had like someone who was
basically daphne and someone who was um
the the scooby hey simon hastings no
um but but they also had they were
dancing
that was pretty
i was pretty good
but they also had and i i thought this
was a fever dream they had someone
dressed as the bee
there's a b yeah
so
there's a bridget and plot point where
someone is allergic to a bee and dies
from a beast
and so dressed as someone
in there what is this show in the
romance i thought it was softcore porn
for tear booze
yeah it is but they're they're a
dramatic moment like someone dying i'm
not saying a bee
flies up you're like yeah
it's the 1800s they don't know how they
know how to deal with anaphylactic shock
anyway so there was a dancer
in the performance dressed up like a bee
and just terrorizing people and i was
like
how do you know it's great your
character has anaphylactic shock or not
though or how do you know oh no no like
they didn't kill anyone
that was going to be the plot point of
the night too when you say someone's
dressed up as a being is terrorizing
people i can only imagine the b guy from
simpsons
terrorizing people dressed as victorian
people victorian bee well that's the
thing and so when we went i was like how
many dudes do you think are going to be
here like really basically no that was
no every single guy one dude who yeah
yeah i i also turned out new one dude
because i i bumped into patrick from
cnet and i was like hey i know one other
dude that went kevin cuellar of kind of
funny did he he's i think he went
yesterday oh yeah he put a picture up he
looked amazing in his outfit it was so
cool that's the thing like some people
who went like fully committed and then
there was uh some people who were just
like no i'm not gonna do that but we
fully committed we had a great time
tackle that beat to the ground yeah
exactly my revenge on it
crush the bee yeah
protect the bees okay yeah
and it was another great day of
protecting us honey sorry the woman from
tick tock who's like always on my for
you page the b lady
he's always picking out the queen
oh it's that ladies yes yes
yeah i just get the guy who screams did
you get him with a beard he'll react to
stuff no
algorithm needs something matt padgett
is still watching he has the weirdest
tic-tac algorithm i've ever seen and he
keeps sending me some of his
and it's now infected my for you page
because like i get these weird ones and
i just send i just send them to matt
yeah matt sends me um on tick tock and i
have had to remind myself not to like
them
right but even watching them that's
enough man watching them is enough but
if you like them then it's all like oh
you want this now now that's all we just
shove it in there so like i just don't
like any of the ones you almost need a
separate tick-tock algorithm yeah that's
the tv
tv okay that's what you just watched
the cursed ones yeah how does so you're
just sitting at home and you're like i
want to watch some cursed tic tacs and
you pull them up on your like on my big
screen yeah yeah because it doesn't
treat the same for some reason like as
far as i know the it doesn't understand
that i have a phone algorithm so like
none of my usual ones come up so but
it's the same account the same account
yeah interesting okay it's just device
to device one way around you've got bean
wizard uh hey you peekaboo asks if
you've had bean wizard on tick tock
because i've had him oh is he under can
i interest you in some steamed beans
[Music]
bean is great
he just wears like a little tin foil hat
and he opens it and there's just beans
on his head but green beans not baked
yes okay and he appears underneath like
the porch yeah and he like
he's great he's great love being wizards
anything else lucy
no no great cool yeah cat update has
peanuts uh peter's great she uh i sent
you did i send you the picture yeah
early today so i was i was doing my
meetings
from uh in the morning from home um
because
you know
that commute life i'm not about it
anymore um and i was sitting on the
couch and i put every time i sit on the
couch i put the blanket on my knee
because i'm an old woman and there's a
knee
peanut like
lay down on me and i was talking to
jesse and we were having a one-on-one
and peanut just was like hello
just started rolling over on her back
and i was just like normal
i've started a new series which you got
the first episode of yeah i did but i
was asleep
where is she going where i just point
the phone at my cat and she awkwardly
looks at me for a little while and i say
where is she going and then she just
like will slowly turn away and then i
follow her to see where she goes and
then i send it like like a gta and pc
have you seen that on tick tock there's
the guy who follows red dead and yeah
just where they're going where they're
going it's wild this is that one
character who's like lost isn't he oh
he's looking for gavin gavin
have you seen my friend gavin gavin i've
followed him around for a really long
time i don't think that's been solved
yet no he doesn't really know gavin's
gone gavin's fully dead i think gavin's
dead no cause don't yeah i thought that
was part of the yeah when i come back
yeah um yeah when you come back later
he's given up right right he's like
running out of the show and he's like
yeah he's like
broken a broken man do you find out
about gavin too no i don't think i'm
fine i know about gavin i think i think
he's or someone in the chat creed says
in the chat i'm pretty sure it's been
solved oh it has you can find a note you
find a note if you kill him oh oh did he
kill gavin whoa
i think he might have killed gavin and
then he's like oh obviously my friend
gavin
um that is a good way to
man gavin is an alter of his oh oh okay
so you are
gavin all these people you know
giving their takes about gta 6 with that
story that went up on
thursday um uh
and cool i'm looking forward to gta 6
but man i would be just as happy if
rockstar was like hey we're going to do
a sadie adler dlc yo
that like honestly that that is what i
[ __ ] want i just want more red dead
like i yeah peop people want gta so bad
but uh no just coming with you yeah that
makes money man
red dead online is dead
so sad the original red dead online i
spent so many hours in it was so fun
yeah because that was the first one with
i think that was the first one with the
open world yeah it's the same map yeah
right
and i don't think gt gta 4 had an open
world gta 4 kind of did but i don't
think it
they didn't quite nail it in that way in
the way that right gta 4 was a nightmare
to get into multiplayer yeah i think it
would break and you have to use that
stupid phone and yeah oh yeah nightmare
ridiculous um but yeah
i'm excited to see gta 6. i i actually
am really excited about the expanding
like if they're adding oh yeah gta
that's that's kind of funny because they
did they've done that for a while right
remember where you had access to like a
core part of um
the uh liberty city was in in gta iii i
think it was whatever the city oh how
sometimes you'd start and you start and
then it'll be like now you can go over
here it's just like going back to that
idea they did the same thing with i
think in vice city where you had access
to different parts or did that too yeah
as well so it's like kind of that but on
a larger scale yeah um i'm surprised
that they're stepping away from multiple
characters
i guess that takes a lot of time and
effort well no they said it would be two
two right
three three yeah yeah yeah
yeah i thought they were gonna go
there's a whole six people you can write
players or whatever
um but it doesn't make sense that
they're doing a bonnie and clydesdale
um
yeah
but i think that will help their weird
like zoom in zoom out tech as well
like two people that can increase the
fidelity of what any one person is doing
at a weird time has anybody seen the guy
who's recreating simpson's hit and run
oh yeah oh yeah oh no no in what in uh
and he implemented that in his latest
video and it looks so cool and you know
if you switch between like characters
i'm sorry i forget what your name is
who's making that don't worry you're
doing an amazing job
i wouldn't worry too much but fox is
going to shut that [ __ ] down in about 10
minutes yeah
exactly um i hope i hope that person
makes it to the finish line yes before
someone else figures it out i think he
was actually saying it's like it's not
going to be released he's just doing it
for fun like
you don't think so
i mean i don't think i told you i told
you the uh
the story about uh
i would love to play someone needs to
remake that game properly yeah that game
is good who even has the simpsons yeah
thq though who did hit and run right
yeah yeah yeah um thq did some i think i
don't know there's the simpsons movie
game
embracer probably has it who knows
it probably has it yeah like the
embracer probably doesn't even know that
they have it
because they have everything yeah i
guess we have it anyways um i've been
playing mostly bear and
um which is great
uh very very chill i highly recommend it
finished resident evil 3
oh cool not so great
um remake um sadly it kind of falls
apart at the end well it falls apart
after about the first hour and then
you're like this is at least okay and
then it's like prepared to be very not
okay
what are your expectations for four
coming out of that i think that four
will be fine okay like i don't think i
don't think resident evil 3
remake is any indication of the quality
that of resident evil 4
i think three was developed concurrently
to two
with a different or like a a smaller
team i i believe
and
it's a very different kind of game that
i think they needed would have had to
invest more time money and resources
into
redesigning resident evil 3 from the
ground up to be a better game if they
wanted to do that which is they didn't
have to do that for two because two was
already exceptional like they knew right
that they could take the bones of it and
the bones of it were enough to
just be a lot if they had just done a
straight one for one port of that game
it would have been amazing right
regardless but like they went the extra
mile introduced the better stuff around
mr x and and like made that better but
three is like the action focused one and
it was kind of weird at that time and
they just stuck kind of
mostly to the letter of the law on that
one they had some divergence and and
introduced a few new things that mostly
didn't work but
it felt very empty i think it's it's an
okay game right it's a very
noticeable step down as the follow-up to
resident evil 2 remake which is one of
the greatest games ever made that's so
good um
but i don't think four i think four is
too big of a project for them to screw
it up i think there's there's
i reckon they delay that as many times
as they need i reckon they are very very
careful about development on that
um and i believe it's all internal as
well now so i don't think they're taking
any risks with that interesting um
um at all i think it's being developed
internally
i might be wrong on that but um
yeah i don't think they're taking any
risks with that and the thing they put
out will be at that very least
good um right but i imagine they're
targeting nines intense for that yeah um
so
and like i said the fundamentals of that
are already rock solid like they
released a vr version of it the other
month or whatever it was and it was like
amazing right but yeah i played that and
honestly glad to be done with it even
though it's like five or six hours
um and then after that i've just kind of
been meandering on what to play
i did a stream yesterday was like what
can i play and end up playing a flash
game for like two hours
for no reason did you say you're the top
streamer i was the number one streamer
of that game oh my god i was the only
streamer well now that's all you can
play yeah yeah once you found this one
yeah you're stuck you can't do the same
nanaka crash
it's just a really dumb game where you
it's actually a spin-off of a hentai
game
yeah i i've
never seen the source material it's one
of those ones where it was like passed
around school because it was like really
dumb fun but it's like you play as a
tentacle no he's just a dude that starts
like he's just a random dude like a good
looking
anime dude and a girl with a bike hits
him
and launches him into the air and then
he just keeps bouncing and along the
ground are like various other characters
who i assume in the original are very
like
naked and pawned up
but in this they're just like normal
looking school
people and like they all have different
properties like one of them if you
collide with them will stop you in your
tracks the other one will like do a cool
uppercut which will send you further
high or like or further and the whole
goal is like how long can you keep this
lad bouncing along this whole thing and
you've got like certain points where if
you're on the decline and you hit the
attack button the girl on the bike will
teleport and like hit you downwards or
if you're on the incline she'll hit you
upwards so you can like but you've only
got like a limited amount of them so you
like time is just
earn like lots of like um distance for
it
it's really dumb but it's one of those
like very easy to get obsessed with
getting higher scores games and like i
was playing it on twitch and then people
in my chat were like what is this game
and i explained it to them no and they
watched it and they were like i am now
playing this game and i cannot stop oh
nice so it's like one of those though
but i will find something new to stream
it's probably going to be sims maybe
next next um stream i'll give that a go
also we were talking about tick tocks
and i could not stop saying hummus last
night
have you seen that picked up oh good
there's a dude obsessed with who moose
and then
this other guy comes in and he's like
laughing and then he uses the filter to
turn his face into pingu yep and he's
like moose
is so funny yeah i mean
saying who moves to my cat constantly
since then but yeah that i played
resident evil or played nanika crash for
a bit um
and then i've been what i've been
watching
i've been watching honestly i've been
watching retry the
rkg series
and it's totally been making my way
through that i've been rereading sandman
to prepare for the upcoming
um tv show sandman
um which is uh i've read i've read that
series a bunch of times i'm very i've
realized i've been
i'm now able to put a positive spin on
the fact that i literally cannot
remember anything anymore
in in that i'm like what reading sandman
i mean like oh i forgot this happens and
i'm like experiencing it almost for the
first time again even though i've read
that series probably like 10 times over
my lifetime
i'm just like oh i forgot about this oh
this is nice and this this is like and
it's also
if you if you are inebriated in any ways
if you want to read that
it's a good time
it's a real good time i'll tell you i
need to finish reading it
i was going to point to you and say like
i need a berserk update from you because
you started reading berserk yeah
i finished the first
four
volumes like the bigger collector's
edition volumes i've got the next two
nice and get through those sometime soon
i guess this last week would have been a
good week to do it since i
had [ __ ] all to do
yeah
where did you fall off uh i haven't
fallen off i took a break to read a book
um series
yeah no i regret it so yeah one of those
ones without pictures
no but it was a spicy book um
which was funny because when we went to
the lake uh kristen our friend was
reading it and i was like tick tock and
she was like yeah technology oh
book recommendations are terrible no
like i'm not even enjoying this
bookstores i've been to yeah i yes
recommended oh yeah i've seen that i'm
like that's unlucky
you know it's like it's one of those
books it's the sarah j maas uh court of
thorns and roses and i was like i just
wanted like a fantasy book because i
love like high fantasy and i'm waiting
for lord of the rings uh rings of power
and so i was just like
i'm really i'm on the fourth one i'm
just like the story is basically
finished this is like a mop-up book
um but i'm still ready where are they
now
yeah pretty much just like oh the big
war is finished and uh this is cleaning
up but uh i got up to the end of 15.
so i finished all the flashlights
15. now i finished all the flashback
stuff and then it was uh the timeline
caught up and i was like this is a good
break point for a little bit because i
don't want to do the thing that i did
with sopranos which is where it was all
i watched
all day every day and then i burned
myself out yeah at the start of season
five um and i don't want that to happen
which is where that's where i'm at right
now oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no sports
just finishing season
i'm on the last episode of season four
i'm
r.i.p uh in real life yeah paulie walnut
paulie walnuts if you are looking for
some fantasy books check out between two
fires
like that by zach galifianakis no
it's by christopher buellman i think
what's it called between two i think
it's called between two fires i just
looked it up because i was like oh yeah
oh yeah between two fires i read a
couple weeks ago it's really good uh oh
thank you
yeah i mean oh during the black plague
yes oh
it's
it's pretty dark i would say i'm in yeah
but i mean but also um i think i've
talked about talking to
jesus christ i think i've talked about
this on the podcast where i've got a uh
i've got the black plague
i've got a goose neck stand that i
clipped to my bed and i have a bluetooth
kindle page turner so i can just lie
fully
and you
you laugh at me but i told our friend
jen about this jen got it and jen just
texted me she was like this has [ __ ]
changed my life oh my god so i just
that's the most
if i'm laying down
like as as as if i'm in sleeping mode
there's no way i'm making it through
even but that's the thing i
lie down i have such a good bed set up
because i also have a heated mattress
topper so like half an hour before i go
to bed i turn that on
i get my i brush my teeth wash my face
go to bed bed is warm
start
turn on my book
because that's the modern hellscape we
live in yep and then i just can't apply
there and then the cat joins me and it's
great how quickly do you fall asleep
most nights with that setup because i
would it would be 15 seconds and i'm
done it depends on how tired i am
sometimes i could genuinely just like
read for ages okay um
but then on monday night i tried to do
and i fell asleep within maybe half a
page so it just depends
um
there's a book called tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow
tomorrow yes exactly like a great wave
or something on the cover yes it does
yes which i think you
will all maybe enjoy i can read the
synopsis tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow two kids meet in a hospital
gaming room in 1987. one is visiting her
sister the other is recovering from a
car crash the days and months are long
they love of video games becomes a
shared world of joy escape and fierce
competition but all too soon that time
is over when the pair spot each other
eight years later in a crowded train
station they are catapulted back to that
moment the spark is immediate and
together they get to work on what they
love making games to delight challenging
and immersing players finding an
intimacy in digital worlds that eludes
them in their real lives their
collaboration makes them superstars this
is the story of perfect worlds sadie and
sam build the imperfect worlds they live
in and of everything that comes after
success money fame duplicity and tragedy
wow that seems like it feels like uh
from what i've heard about it i've not
actually read it but i'm going to be
right um it's very referential
but
[Music]
i love akira
it's more like uh a kind of like people
bonding over shared things so if you
want another book to read that's a good
one i was waiting for a deez nuts joke
at the end of that scene yeah just the
way you were presenting it
i was on edge i was waiting for it it's
got a great review here
yeah thank you green on instagram i
cannot recommend it highly enough cheers
from instagram
yeah from instagram that's an instagram
reviewer yeah just hank green no but
like the hank green i assume it's the
high priest no it's hank green from
instagram
yeah
otherwise what it says he's not known
he's not known for anything else but
being on instagram wait that's the
username is hank green from instagram
it is probably that probably yeah but
this is it says hank green instagram
that's so funny
i said who's seen nope here nope no i've
seen it because there's a there's a
great accurate reference in that too oh
i think you might say there's a great
hank green reference underneath
that one's actually in the trailer too
that roughly it is yeah not the trailer
or something it ended up on twitter
because i said oh i've been trying to
use it
is it it's just the cape
no is it him walking towards a horse
no okay cool no no that's not the
obvious reference you can look it you
can you you'll notice
when you see it you'll get it
i might try and go and watch it soon
great movie um
but yeah okay let's move on
to the next part of the show
which is the question of the week thank
you maria
question of the week
we don't have jingles do we no don't be
good certainly not
um
yeah yeah
um this obviously comes from if you're
not familiar maria serious business in
the game sport discord
has a specific channel which is called
question of the week where people
um go in to chat about the question of
the week which is posed by maria if you
want to get into our discord um you can
send myself a lucy a message on twitter
and we will conduct some quick checks to
make sure you're not wrong how many how
many checks are you connecting i conduct
a check every single time like if
someone messages me and they're like hey
i want in a discord i will find their
profile i'll go through their tweets to
make sure i'll check their likes and if
they can check their lives oh yeah if
they're like if they're like
yeah well i don't want some dude who's
like
[ __ ] like letting them in
and if they don't have anything on their
twitter i will go the extra mile and
look on other potential places like
instagram facebook wow yeah sometimes
they just don't exist then i'm not a man
sometimes i'll find their address too
and yeah yeah yeah and just like google
map it and send it
inside
the the discord is a very wholesome nice
place where no wronglands are currently
at and i'd like to say true i'd like to
say that is because i go the extra mile
to make sure yes okay
and i will on occasion if you do ask and
i do request your social security number
don't worry just send me something this
is part of the process this is part of
the process not an issue although i
think we do plan on opening it up soon
yeah i think we do as well we haven't
talked about it oh that goes up the
window yeah yeah yeah it's fine so maria
posed the question what is the hardest
decision you've had to make in a video
game
this is a good one because we all play
games that are very decision focused so
i don't know if this is the hardest
decision but the one that i always think
of is when you have to choose between
ashley and cayden and mass effect one
that's right that's not how hard is it i
know well it i i guess it was a space
race it was exceptionally boring i think
the first time through it's a hard one
the first yeah it's hard because i went
there with the
with the anticipation right that
whichever character stays behind or
whatever is not going to be in the rest
of the games because that's what they
had said yeah and i knew someone had to
die and i remember getting to that and
setting down my control and taking
longer than i would have expected to
shepherd we gotta we gotta do this bomb
thing wait yeah exactly wait now it's a
pretty easy decision to make yeah
um
ashley of course i always pick actually
every single time yeah
what was i playing oh i mean
uh the quarry had a good i had a good
few like had scratches when it came to
decision making well because i
accidentally got my sweet dylan killed
so which one was dylan again my favorite
the um
the guy oh the the uh wisecracking a
wisecracking guy yeah okay i loved him
um i accidentally got him killed and so
i had to think really hard about whether
or not whether or not to just completely
restart the game so it's not worth
better yeah
that dude is barely seen again from that
point onwards
um
i'm trying to think of one that's like
not mass effect because i feel like
that's my default and also i've been
playing myself again
um
i mean
[Music]
the one at the end of dark souls is
pretty yeah it's pretty big it's pretty
big one because you're like i mean a lot
of people accidentally make the
make a decision not knowing there's an
alternative you can either walk to the
you know age of dark or like rekindle
but that one is like a one where you're
like oh my god it led or all that was
for this moment and it's like not
necessary you don't really know what's
at stake
to a degree it's just a gravitas of that
moment and the the journey uphill that
you've climbed that you're like
ah which one should i do is this gonna
matter is it how is it gonna matter will
i understand it right and like
if you're a true gamer you do both
yeah i was going to say because alden
ring has a lot of different endings and
the first time i played through it i had
a choice between three i think yeah but
i that was an easy choice because i was
going to replay it i don't know this one
that seemed like the most work to get
because when i replay it i won't have to
do it again but i ended up doing it
anyway because
um yeah
it is a lot of mass effect isn't it well
what about um
which decision i messed up but i ended
up getting the worst ending in the
witcher 3.
um
the
there's it's not really a tough decision
but one of my favorite decisions in the
witcher 3 is when you have to decide
whether to help that that tree spirit or
whatever
and
you don't know if it's good or bad and
you don't really know what's going to
happen if you do it and no matter what
you pick is kind of [ __ ] but one ending
is like really bad
or one not ending but one ending to that
arc is really bad and i remember re
setting the first time i played through
refreshing because i was like wow
we just obliterated an entire town [ __ ]
that i need that town
there's also the the another mass effect
one where you choose whether or not to
give the elusive man access to
the reaper the reaper yeah we're like it
makes a really good
like compelling case for one
giving it to him because he's he has
spent a lot of time like doing stuff
that helps humanity but then you all
there's a really good um depiction or
like characterization of him being like
this guy's up to no good clearly so it's
like ah i could make a case for either
yeah um that's a really good one the
biggest thing that holds mass effect's
decision making back though is the
morality system that they have because
yeah i would just blindly pick things
because i'd be playing paragon and
renegade and i just picked renegade
which
i i know they got rid of an andromeda
and i hope in mass effect 4 they've also
learned to leave that mass effect 5
reboot i don't know the next massive i
hope they decide to leave that behind
because that that sort of
morality meter was very of its time and
i don't think it's aged well it kind of
robs
those decisions the wrecks
the decision oh yeah yeah i remember
losing him the first time yeah because
if you'd if you don't if you're paragon
or renegade he's not high enough he dies
no matter what yeah
that's a yeah
if he dies that [ __ ] sucks
that is a restart the game yeah because
he's then removed from two other games
he's in two as well isn't he yes he is
he's the yeah yeah clan leader yeah and
three and like you do not want to play
those two games without rex yeah yeah
yeah i mean there's some good krogens in
it but is it reeve they put in there
instead
yes
yeah so you know
and then you've got grunt in three to
kind of be him but
not quite um you need rex in all of
those you need that boy um
yeah i think that it's weird i just
can't think of any other decision making
moments in any other game
life is strange i guess like oh yeah uh
fallout for sure to uh oh megaton
yup that was my that was my choice
that's a good one yeah oh my god there's
the rock it can you choose to fire off
the uh the spaceships and follow new
vegas too yes yeah
that's another great one yeah oh um not
high-fiving duck in walking dead
oh yeah walking dead's probably got some
good ones too i just don't know it's
been a long time yeah
yeah a lot of people are saying the
quality in the discord
um oh i mean yeah there's stuff in in
dragon age yeah um
anders
yeah but isn't anders voiced by that guy
who was the same voice as cullen who
kind of went off the deep end oh no
yeah oh no oh the uh the flash that guy
no different guy
different guy
yeah different there's a lot of guys
going off deep into right now you know
what i'm saying
yeah
other
there's a lot of uh people uh
some of the choices life in life is
strange true colors
um uh hen dubs which is a great name uh
says um were quite difficult
um and then some of the choices in in on
the suicide mission at the end of mass
effect 2 were rough yeah that final
decision
or that final sequence where you have to
make a lot of decisions at once is quite
see that's better too because that
doesn't affect your paragon or renegade
that is
you using what you know from these
characters to put them in the situations
that you think are best and if they're
not
too [ __ ] bad right
i think a decision that all of us can
probably um agree was tricky is the
first pokemon game you ever played oh
yeah
the starters yeah yeah oh yes because
like you had you had like no frame of
reference at that point no it was like
do i pick the fire lizard or the yeah
and then if it's your first pokemon game
you pick charmander you are going to get
wrecked for the first two years right
exactly exactly you're probably not even
going to realize that if you picked
another one it would have been a lot
easier yeah i wouldn't squirtle i went
squirtle first time nice and i don't
regret it i'm in bulbasaur
my first no i got roasted for picking
bulbasaur my first game was pokemon
yellow so
that's me too nice nice my first real
one was uh mudkip which is that uh
yeah
i like that uh pokemon games now
released the starters really early i
mean i'm sure they did before but it's
nice because you can start thinking
about it in advance get a bunch of
annoying twitter takes on which one's
the best though you know
yeah what is it what's the feeling about
the new ones
like
aussius dr seuss or jose i'm not a
pokemon person i'm i've forgiven myself
for never really finishing them i just i
i do i always buy it and i'm like i'm
just talking about this jake you're more
i play the hell out of them i'm excited
for it i don't know
i'm at the point where i
have a pretty good idea of what i'm
gonna get out of it you know like
they could change around the main game
formula they could add cool new pokemon
i know i'm going to play a lot of the
post game stuff because that's what i
normally do
yeah uh the what they've shown so far
they seem pretty cute so i don't know
i'm curious to see what
yeah crocodile thing whatever the uh
what's the what's the little
pig one i like the people oh that guy
was chunk
yeah yeah
yeah i'm i'm excited but i
i don't know pokemons are weird at this
point yeah it's a whole can of worms i'm
sure i'll get into it it feels like that
comes out more than anything it feels
the one franchise that i definitely feel
like i aged out of
if you know what i mean yeah like very
few other things where like i still
watch anime i still like will be into
various things that people would say are
for kids but i don't know there's
something about pokemon that makes me
feel like i might have aged out of it i
still play them and i enjoy them but i
don't derive the same kind of like
obsession to it as i used to maybe i'm
just like tired of it that's how i felt
until i got more into the competitive
side and then i got
back into it i would say so now when you
see a lot of people on the internet
complaining about the story in pokemon
games being too childish or whatever i
get that
uh and it kind of bums me out a little
but at the end of the day
all of them were kind of childish
it's not for you but it's the same it's
the same story yeah yeah where it's like
yeah it's because it was a there were
movies for kids and you're an adult and
you're mad that the movie's fake yeah
that's exactly appealing to you yeah
yeah i will say though arceus did some
cool [ __ ] like that was interesting i i
had fun with that i think you know
the issue with me is that the post game
wasn't there so when i was done with it
i i there wasn't much of a reason to
keep playing right yeah
there you have it
another episode of the gamespot after
dark podcast live
is complete
um thank you everyone for watching if
you're watching on twitch please do
consider hitting the follow button if
you're on giant bomb
please click through and hit the follow
button it helps us massively and if
you're listening to this on a podcast
app please do go to your podcast service
of choice and rate and review us if you
can if you like us five stars only don't
give up
come on now you're gonna give us four
stars just go away okay we don't want to
see any of that
um
once again if you want to send us emails
you can do that to after dark podcasts
at gamespot.com or it's easier um if you
do it in the discord yep um because then
you get um a bunch of others chatting to
you as well nice people nice nice um
background check people exactly you get
background checked
um i'll do a credit check on you as well
for free credit karma yeah
lucy where you at where you where can
people find you
i'm on twitter
twitch instagram everything lucy james
games uh what am i doing oh i did a
video um
i'm doing kind of like a roundup every
month now what's going to be on ps plus
because obviously that has changed to be
like three tiers and also they're
putting
all the yakuza games on there so spoiler
alert that that video is just gonna be
me saying play yakuza
um but basically kind of just trolling
through the old playstation catalog and
seeing what's on there
so that's a new thing that i'm working
on and then other than that we've got
some
secret stuff that i can't talk about
just yet
steve what about you uh i am at stewie
review on
uh twitter s-t-u-e-y i think that's
important uh and s kimball 97
on instagram i think if i remember and i
am on day three so yeah i haven't
actually given you anything to do yes
i haven't given you anything to do yet i
think the only thing i've given you to
do is like
talk to your onboarding mentors right
exactly like do the things that they
tell you to do yeah just meet people
that's exactly what i'm doing but i'm
very thankful thank you so much for
having me on um
and hope to do it again yeah
jake
uh you can find me at jacob deck and
check out my xenoblade chronicles 3
review yes
and i'm at tomorrow on pretty much
everything
um twitter twitch i i don't i don't know
what i'm doing right now i'm doing many
things
i'm doing nothing that is the life i
lead we'll see you next week goodbye bye
bye
[Music]
wow harmonize there in the end
come on oh i'm just gonna do it over
here oh okay
this is what happens when john luke
isn't around i know it's fourth apart
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you